today date this is a nice charming
little episode where Ice King is still
around the place and they kind of want
him to finally get the idea to move away
so they invite over abracadaniel they
start hanging out having all sorts of
fun together and then they look at Finn
sword read this magic writing out there
that brings back the demon that you know
did all these terrible things and he
threatens to kill them and then he says
who kill them if they don't break the
sword they broke the sword he becomes
powerful he takes Jake disappears and
that's the end
you look yeah definitely
start out very playful very friendly and
then just like what is you know like
really intense dark which I like I like
it again when you can't predict where
it's gonna go um cuz I was for watching
this episode like I like it I'm enjoying
it but I'm like it like I wish maybe we
could get back to one of the ones that
had a little bit more of a story or you
know something connecting to sort of
like you know the drama that they do
before and then just like boom out of
nowhere get what you want yeah so very
well placed you know just in the scheme
of things uh and and it it's funny I
like the I love seeing the Ice King and
Africa Dara abracadaniel excuse me uh
hang out and I love seeing Finn and Jake
serve as the parents like reading their
books and yeah the coffee and stuff like
this is nice this is nice it's you know
while they're going around acting like
kids pretty much and try and putting out
a little show cuz end and pretty much
getting into trouble and they give
little lies and stuff I I did call one
thing though at the very beginning I
said hey wait a minute Kim has is crown
bag that's go to her head the crown so
yeah I did kind of figure out something
was up there cuz it turns out it's been
fixed for weeks
yeah the ice kingdom if you just want to
hang out with Finn and Jake hello who
wouldn't thought yes well what I like is
that they invite him to hang out there
and the past couple times I saw them in
the house
forgot oh yeah he was living there cuz I
was always there like what's he just
doing there and then it's like they've
done that joke a couple of times I'm
like oh wait yeah he's and he would Jake
at the very beginning just our turns
he's like you know guy I keep forgetting
you lives here yeah and I think the
audience kinda knows too cuz they don't
address it that much um especially cuz
you think that'd be a bigger thing you
know can't like what they did in this
episode where he would get annoying and
grading and stuff Oh friends you come
over and do Danby logs I know don't you
hate those people God I have this one
guy who would you know come over and do
the logs of Adventure Time well how'd
you put up with him uh i dink as it was
me and putting up with me is incredibly
easy because I'm awesome but yeah I
liked it I liked the I like how it's
suddenly at the end got like you know
return to sort of the bigger story
that's probably going on at hand and it
leads on nice to be continued and if the
one thing this did that I don't know
like you get older you kind of forget
about this stuff but I kind of forgot
when you're a kid kind of how fun
sleepovers are actually like we just
spend the night who is somebody cuz it's
like you know when you're a kid it's
like just the things are cool you're a
kid you're playing video games you're
eating yeah junk food so it's awesome
but then there's and you're trying to
get away with whatever you can around
your parents but that there's something
cool about going to like another kid's
house and it's like seeing all the toys
and he has and then sharing and
worry it's like what your parents let
you get away with maybe I can get away
with it here instead it's like I sort of
forgot the fun of that and I watching
this again I'm so like oh yeah there was
something really cool about them that is
something I think Adventure Time does
very well so it brings you back to you
know even though there's a lot of adult
stuff in it there's a lot of remembering
those really fun little moments of being
a kid yeah even if it's done with the
dolls I mean both those people were at
all which made a little even funnier um
but yeah no I like dressing up in
costume and doing funny voices and yeah
gay people together
totally child no adults ever dude ya
know adults ever do that or get paid for
it that'd be yeah so yeah that'd be nice
nice shirt for not judging up like any
characters or anything like that no I
don't like you you just go to a
convention just be like yeah this is my
cosplay damn I I'm Jake very slowly
squeezing a man to death I'm in the Jake
suit yes shirt yes indeedy apparently my
laundry's done yes your thoughts oh I
didn't know I know where you're going
with this or anything I'm so out of it
right now
okay I kind of sleepover with my friends
I'm tired now I think that's a life
you're right um I liked it it was a lot
of fun
Ice King if he was living in my house
honestly at this point in the game of my
life I think if anyone lived in this
house besides my wife my daughter my son
or my cat I think I'd be annoyed after
my good day and a half I don't care who
would be it would just be so it would
throw me off so much we've been a family
unit for so long we have routines we
have the way we do things
tossing anyone into it even a great
friend or so Neve known forever they
have their own quirks now they're only
of doing things and it's like I'm just
imagining Finn and Jake putting up with
Ice King for that long and that would
drive me bonkers there is yeah there was
something it's like we both had I mean
if people are you bad parties you know
we've had people over it's like you know
yeah spend the night you know please no
problem but yeah the idea of something
like living with you for a long time
it's I can't remember the last time like
I've done that with someone like you
know having someone over for like a week
or so it's like the most I think I've
had something over for like two three
days or something yeah yeah I mean it's
that's where an out-of-town friend and
that's about it yeah there there is
something about like you do sort of get
I'm sure
getting older to you just like you so
you getting this you know this formula
going this pattern going they become
really comfortable with and it's like
when somebody else comes in it's like
okay no this is fine for like I'm an
adult come on I'm adaptable and flexible
you know just just for just for a little
bit though just a short amount of time
where like the idea of doing that like
when you're a kid like going on a week
trip or spaying like a week at
somebody's house or something it's just
like the coolest thing ever it's are you
yes that'd be awesome
so um probably the other way around too
it's like if you if you're going to
somebody else's house that it's like you
know oh no that's not even then I don't
know if I could do like a whole weekend
like somebody else's I'd be sleeping in
someone else's bed
yeah I'd start to probably get like a
little like a little homesick should I
be a little paranoid - in a sense of I'd
hate going into their fridge and just
grabbing their food I'd hate like it
would make me feel uncomfortable
yeah like am i overstepping any guy like
it's one of those where I'd have to show
respectful let's say wake up at like
3:00 in the morning do I wake them up
and say hey can I get a snack or do I
not or like what do I do and at the same
time we know there's people that's like
as soon as they move into somebody's
places somebody that's just like if they
just make themselves at home you bit
like nobody told them - no I've been
down that road way too many times yeah
like there's definitely people that do
that too so it's just gonna be like and
I think that's one of the reasons like
the ice king of this it's like yeah you
can just get it very quickly he make me
a sandwich don't forget the bread don't
forget the brass no I liked it it was it
was it was interesting once the demon
showed up I really liked that it's a I
like how the demons holding both Eric
Daniel and the ice canoes like if you
say the worst trend send me back up you
know disintegrate them and Jake just
start saying it it's like I'm saying no
I thought he was bluffing
well how long are the words I mean is it
something where you can say really fast
you won't have a chance to kill em or is
it like a really really long no it's
just pretty short remember
oh god what what's it say I want to say
I don't remember looks like dude yeah I
think they could have done any you know
but this is one thing I'll say
definitely for Finn infants character
Ice King who was his enemy
abracadaniel who's kind of a waste of
space
Ice King who's kind of a waste of space
he's willing to give up one of his fins
going to give up like a prized
possession it wasn't just something he
got in some dungeon I mean yes it is
something he got in some dungeon but but
it means a lot more like its father yeah
you know and all of that stuff he's
willing to break it with you know he's
like I can't and he's like the guys look
around he's like oh you're fine and he
does it like it'd take a lot more for me
to you know important I think than to
people that are not incredibly fond of
yeah that is true it wasn't like you
know people's or something like that II
oh um you know or anything like that
yeah it was just these two pretty
annoying people one that has been an
enemy on several occasions yes so ya
know that's a - a good point I think
you're right it is kind of a testament
to his character what a good kid he is I
mean he's been through a lot of
hardships but even when it comes down to
it he's willing to sacrifice for people
he's not even incredibly fond of so I
liked it it was okay
ya know I thought was good I liked the
ending did really make me say you know
what's gonna happen next one I you know
I got I got into it again cuz I was well
I have like these past episodes but at
the same time I'm like yeah I'm kind of
missing the what's gonna happen next
aspect it's like it came in just at the
right time so yeah yeah no I think
that's really good pacing of the of the
episode this shows good at that it's
good at you know knowing when to give
you served yeah this is just kind of a
waste of time or silliness whatever and
now we're gonna get to like the really
gritty you know story yeah you know in
the heavy drama and stuff so I think
battles are not really good and it's
it's not quite predictable you don't
quite know
all of this episode's gonna be serious
this one's gonna be funny it could start
off totally goofy and then slowly work
its way into you know something really
serious yeah or in this one where it's
just like you know it's mostly goofy
then at the end so you have this big
cliffhanger you oregan the Holly Jolly
secrets right it's just like what is
this building up to and then just like
you know Oh something so dramatic you
know it's just like this big you know
huge puzzle piece that just put so much
together so they're really good at then
they're still really good at just
throwing in these little surprises and
spacing them out oh I agree that's it